Ya ben kan vermekten acayip Korkuyorum
bu öyle iğne korkusu kan görmek korkusu
falan alakası yok şimdi psikolog gibi
çocukluğuma yine bu korkunun temelini
oluşturuyor onu anlatacağım size şu an
altı yaşlarında falandım Annem beni
sabah kahvaltısı için ekmek almak için
bakkala gönderiyor bu mahallemizin
bakalım Mahmut amcadan bir adet ekmek
alıp çok net hatırlıyorum paranın özel
led'i kendime sakız çikolata tarzı bir
şey aldığımı ve annemin kızmayacağım
denemenin oldu aldığımız olarak
hatırlıyorum sonra merdivenleri koşu
çıkıp geri eve döndüğünü hatırlıyorum
merdivenleri koşarak çıktı çok tatlı
böyle ikili ikili çıktı mı Ben eve
girdim anneme ekmeği uzattım parasını
uzattım ameliyesi anne paranın üzeri ile
de bir şey aldım derken
bu birinci mi tamamen kaybediyor bende
bir karanlık var var hayatımda ilk defa
o zaman bayıldım altı yaşlarında falan
bu bilincim yavaş yavaş yerine gelirken
işte annemin ağlaması çok uzaktan böyle
bana seslenilen işte komşularımızdan
gelen sözler bilgi komşumuzu çağırmış
Annem biraz korktuğu için onları
duyuyorum yavaş yavaş böyle bilincim
yerine geldikçe iyice bu kendi kendine
tuvalet eğitimi almış çok erken yaşta
tuvalet kullanmaya başlamış bir çocuk
olarak mükemmel utanç duyduğumu halıda
bıraktım bu izi fark ediyorum şimdi
çocuk olarak belki çok utanç verici bir
şey değil ama ben kendim utancımı çok
net hatırlıyorum
O çok net hatırlıyorum Çünkü şu bunun
kan vermem ne alakası kan vermekten
korkma ne alakası şu benim hiçbir zaman
teşhisi tam olarak konulamayan epileptik
bir düzensizliğim var Hiçbir analiz
sonucunda karakteristik bir özellik
göstermediği için teşhis konulamıyor
Fakat bu her bayıldıktan sonrasında her
bayılma sonrasında artık mükemmel bir
utanç verici bir hal alan ürüner sistem
boşaltımı istemsiz ürüner sistem
boşaltımı durumu maalesef
bu epileptik rahatsızlıkların bir
bir göstergesi
var ama ben bunu artık her kan verdiğim
de yaşadıkça bende artık bu ciddi bir
korku ciddi bir Hobi haline geldi ve ben
bu korku her Rojin analiz tahliye
sıradan bir sağlık raporu için kan
vermem gerektiğini mutlaka ve mutlaka
yaşıyorum imkan verirken de şu sebepten
bayılıyorum sanırım damarlarım
görünmüyor çok rahat burada çok hızlı
kan veremiyorum 10 dakika falan sürüyor
bir kan verme işlemi maalesef Sonuçta
böyle 10 11 denemeden sonra bulunan
damardan böyle Damla Damla gelen kan
artık bir zaman sonra
o Uzmanlar daha iyi bir takım hızlı ve
beni Ne oldu ama bu benim tabii nacizane
görüşüm Artık kan şekerim düşüyor daha
kan basıncı düşüyor bayılıyorum hem de
fazla aynı şey Korkusuz insandan
Korkusuz kadından bahsetmek için önce
korkularımızı tanımlamamız gerekiyor
deyip benim için çok utanç verici olan
bir Korkma paylaştım sizinle E şimdi ben
Rusya'da bir şirkette özel bir şirkette
petrol ve gaz endüstrisinde kalite
kontrol departmanı kaynak mühendisi
olarak çalışıyorum Yıldız Teknik
Üniversitesi makine mühendisliği
mezunuyum aynı zamanda kaynak
mühendisliğim şimdi bu konuşmayı
yapacağımı söylediğin zaman ailem ve
yakın çevrem ilk düşünce olarak bu
tecrübemden
bu gelişimden Bu tamamen erkek Egemen
sektörde söz sahibi bir mühendis
oluşumdan ve çok büyük projeler de bir
Türk kadını olarak çalışıyor olduğundan
vesaire bahsedeceğim düşündüler şimdi
gerçeklere bakarsak
mi Evet belki beni Korkusuz muşum gibi
gösteren bir tecrübe Olabilir çünkü her
yeni girdim ortamda yada değişimden her
bahsettiğim durumda tebrikler tabi ben
şantiyeci olduğu için benim çevrem biraz
daha Kaba Saba Vay be helal olsun gibi
tepkilerle Evet karşılaşıyorum Tabii ki
de beni mutlu ediyor Çok gurur verici
bir şeyler bunlar gurur hissettiriyor
tabii ki de ama o Maalesef ben gerçekten
işin aslına bakarsan çok helal Beylik
bir şey yaptığımı düşünmüyorum çünkü
Sen hiçbir zaman Benim korktuğum birşey
olmadı tam terse beni heyecanlandıran
bir tecrübe oldu bu arada bu tecrübe
Rusya böyle tek başına gelmek de
mükemmel değişik bir tecrübe bir kere
dışında İngilizce konuşma seviyesi çok
turşu maalesef Rusya'da İngilizce
konuşabilen otellerde dahil resepsiyon
İngilizce konuşabilen personel
bulamayabilirsiniz Bu süre İngilizce
konuşabilen insan bulmak gerçekten çok
zor tamamen başka bir alfabe bir şeyler
okuyup birşeyleri bir şeylere benzetme
nizde çok zorrr herhangi birine bir şey
sorduğun zaman şöyle bir tepki
alıyorsunuz Ruslardan
alt Yazım libani mavide başka Aslında
oldukça da kibar bir cümle Ben sizi
anlamıyorum hanımefendi demek Ama şu
Rusya'nın getirdiği o tekdüzelik Bizim
kültürümüzde uzak olması falan var çok
değişik tecrübeler ver masada ilk
çalışmaya amurda başladım amur oblastı
Rusya'nın Uzak Doğu bölgesinde çizim
fırında bir yer Orada küçük bir kasabada
bir gaz Işık meselesinde başladım
Rusya'da çalışmaya
gel buraya gitmek için önce
adana-istanbul istanbul-moskova
Moskova'dan Sekiz saatlik bir blog logo
için uçuşu ardından iki buçuk saatlik
bir karayolu sonrası ancak çalıştım
bölgeye gelebildim şimi İlk gelişim
mükemmel gizemli ydi bana sadece
Moskova'ya kadar uçak biletimi verdiler
ve hiçbir Komutanım olmadan bindim ben
uçağı uçaktan indiğimde Ne yapmam
gerektiği konusunda hiçbir fikrim yoktu
Beni birisi karşılayacak bu
karşılamayacak mı ne yapacağım Hiçbir
fikrim yoktu bunlardan asla korkmadım
demiyorum Bunların hepsi korku birazdan
bahsedeceğim şey de aslında bununla
alakalı
var ama ben benim için herhangi bir
konuda Korkusuz olduğumu hissettiğim an
aslında
bu korkumu yaşamam geri Eğer korku
yaşamam gerekeni yaşamak istediğimi
hayalimi hedefim iyi ertelemesine izin
vermiyorsa İşte ben o zaman kendimi
Korkusuz ediyorum çünkü tekrar kan verme
meselesi ne geleceğim ben ne zaman kan
verecek olsam yaptığım şey elimden
geldiğince kan verme işlemini ertelemek
elimden geldiğince artık Çok korkuyorum
ve erteleye Bildiğim kadar erteliyorum
olmasını geciktirebilirim kadar
geciktiri yorum
ama bana göre korkularımızla Baş
edebilmek için bu bizim bir çeşit
savunma başa çıkma mekanizma mız
Erteleme Ben bu işi çok başarılıyım
Allah korkusu hissediyorum korkusu
hissetmiyorum noktasına gelirsek Şimdi
biz Ataerkil toplumlarda yaşayan
kadınlar olarak bak zaten her şeyden
korumamız gerektiği temizlenerek
büyüyoruz size karanlıkta yürümekten
korkuyoruz yalnız yaşamaktan korkuyoruz
yalnız yürümekten korkuyoruz
başarısızlıktan korkuyoruz dışarıdan
korkuyoruz güçsüzlükten korkuyoruz
güçten korkuyoruz erkeklerden korkuyoruz
ve bu Korkular artık Maalesef bu
toplumlarda Turkey toplumlarda artık
dna'mızda işlenmiş vaziyeti bunu
değiştirmek için
Bu bir şeyler yapabilir miyiz Evet
yapabiliriz ama bunu değiştirmek için
bana göre yapmamız gereken hiçbir şeyden
korkmayan Gözü Kara bireyler yetiştirme
mize Gözü Kara bireyler olmamız değil
tam tersine korkularımızı sahipleri bu
korkularımızın var olduğunu bilinçli bir
şekilde kabul edip bu korkuların
yaşamlarımızı ertelemesine izin
vermediğimiz İzin vermeyen kadınlar
olmamız gerekiyor işte o zaman Bence
toplumun
bu Korkusuz kadın
bu görüşünü değiştirebiliriz çünkü
bu Korkusuz kadın Korkusuz insan hiçbir
şeyden korkmayan insan demek değil Çünkü
Korkular her zaman var ve her zaman var
olacaklar Ben hayatım boyunca Rusya'da
yaşamak burada çalışmak istedim bu
sektörde bu sektörde hep çalışmak
istedim şimdi Dolayısıyla Rusya benim
için Hayal ülkelerden bir tanesi de
sektörün burada çok geniş olmasından
sebep bahsettiğim Herşeyden olayı plana
başvurdum anlar Rusya geldiğim ana kadar
Evet çok heyecanlıydım Evet benim için
daha çok başarı hikayesi iyiydi ama
mi Evet beni Korkusuz yapmadı buraya
gelip bunları başarmış olmam burada
çalışıyor olmam ama evet korktun dedim
ya biletin sadece Moskova'ya kadar bir
Moskova'da beni kim karşılayacak ne
yapacak hiçbir fikrim yoktu
o Rusya'da Rusça bilmeden kendi kendine
sahip çıksın çok mümkün değil Mahallesi
bu Eğer ben o İlkay ilanı gördüm de bu
yolculuk bu tecrübe gözümde bilseydi
kopmuş olsaydım bunlardan daha doğrusu
bu Korkma yenik düşüp Her zaman yaptığım
çok iyi yaptığım şeyi ertelemeyi yapmış
olsaydım Belki de oğluyla anda 12 öz
geçmiş geride kalacaktım ve şu anda
gerçekten içinde olmaktan çok mutlu
olduğum yaşamaktan çok mutlu olduğum
yaşamı benim yerime
mı başka bir erkek yaşıyor olacaktı
toplantılarla Masalı benim yerime Yine
başka bir erkek olacaktı başka bir
Mahallesi olacaktı
ve tüm bu korkularımızla karşı Korkusuz
bir tavır sergile yemezsek
Ama bu bizlere maalesef ertelenmiş
Hayatlar a ertelenmiş hayallere sebep
olacak ertelenmiş Hayaller de mal olacak
Yani benim Demem ki Ataerkil toplumlarda
Korkusuz kadınlar olmak için gerçekten
hiçbir şeyden korkmayan mükemmel Cesur
mi Evet ben her şeyi yapabilirim diyen
kadınlar olmaktansa var olan soru
işaretleri mizi Acaba ben bunu yapabilir
miyim korkularımızı ben bunu başarabilir
miyim korkularımızı sahiplenip Bu
soruların bu korkuların bizlerin
hayallerinin ertelenmesine izin
vermemeyi öğrenmemiz lazım cümleyi
kuramadım galiba Hatta Yani demek
istediğim şu korku her zaman var ve her
zaman var olacak Her zaman bir şeylerden
korkmayacağız kan vermekten
korkmayacağız iğne olmaktan korkacağınız
köpeklerden korku cağız Herşeyden
korkmayacağız Ama eğer bu korkularımız
hayallerimize yaşamak istediğimiz hayata
yapmak istediğimiz şeylere başarmak
istediğimiz hedeflere Eğer bir erteleme
getireceksin
bu çünkü bu ertelemenin maalesef sonu
yok işte o zaman korkularımızla yenik
düşmüş oluyoruz o zaman korkusu insanlar
olamıyoruz
bu Korkusuz kadınlar korkun hayallerini
ertelemeleri ne İzin vermeyen kadınlar
olacaklar